along with video game adaptations being
more popular than ever thanks to
successes like the last of us and the
Super Mario Brothers movie may make fans
think a GTA film could still be on the
table but it'd be best not to hold your
breath Strauss zelnick the CEO of take
two interactive spoke with the rap in
2019 about the possibility of a GTA
movie at some point saying part of it is
if we were to do something like that
we'd want to have complete creative
control to make sure we express GTA in
the way we wanted and that would mean
we'd need to finance that motion picture
he and others who work at Take 2 aren't
super familiar with the film industry so
he doubts they could adequately adapt
the franchise into a movie simply put he
just doesn't trust anyone else to do GTA
Justice zelnick added you have the most
valuable intellectual property ever
created by mankind Grand Theft Auto we
wholly own and control it are we really
going to let go of that and hope that
someone no matter how talented they are
will do a really good job with it